one of the few scheduled flights still
in the erred lands that you can throw
passengers for now able to pass through
the airport and into the UK without
checks or restriction but that is about
to change with the government preparing
to require all new arrivals with the
exception of those in the Republic of
Ireland to enter a 14-day quarantine
period reversing existing policy as we
get the on but the reproduction number
down in the UK and we begin to get
things under control and we now have the
capacity as we just discussed in testing
as well it clearly then makes sense to
look at what happens at the borders
earlier this year the UK quarantine more
than 200 passengers on flights from
Wuhan China but has since let travelers
come and go freely but in Italy all
arrivals are required to quarantine for
14 days
the same rules apply in Germany which
imposes a two-week period of isolation
and France will impose a 14-day period
with the exception of travelers from the
Schengen zone and the UK for an airline
industry already dealing with a 95
percent reduction in traffic it is a
nother blow passenger levels in the UK
are typically 98 or 99 percent down on
where they were before and I think
that's just not a level that you can
sustain for a long period of time
businesses simply cannot continue in an
undo for an under unending period
without any kind of revenues the
rationale is that with the outbreak
under control quarantine can help keep
it that way
but it effectively means the end of
international travel for now Heathrow
would normally be the busiest airport in
Europe but it's reduced to just a
handful of flights and this crisis could
change air travel for a generation there
have already been nearly 20,000
redundancies of British carriers and
many more could follow and the impact on
tourism will be felt right across the
industry